ve eşitsizlikler dendiğinde ilk
Hissettiğim şey öfke oldu Aklıma ilk
gelen şey de fırsatçılık oldu sonra
aklıma ilk gelen şeyin fırsatçılık
hissettiğim şeyinde öfke olmasını kafam
takıldı biraz içerledim e Böyle
zamanlarda ilk yaptığım şey hemen
çocuklara ve doğaya bakmak oluyor benim
çocuklar da ve doğada Böylesi bir
fırsatçılık ve öfke görmüyorum Biz
büyükler bunu yarattık bu tohumları Biz
eksik Şimdi bunu büyük bitiriyoruz sonra
da Bunlar çok şikayet ediyoruz ev his
açılır şöyle anlatmak istiyorum
çocukların kadınların hayvanların
tohumun toprağa Doğan haklarını savunmak
istiyoruz eşitsizlikleri eşitliği
kavuşturmak istiyoruz ve bunlar için
yapılan bütün eylemlerin çoğunda tek
çare sanki ki inadına söylemleri İntikam
naraları öfke ve ve sövme
bu ve hatta biraz vicdan pornosuu Bundan
başka bir çare ve seçenek yokmuşçasına
biz buna daha daha daha sürükleniyoruz
bunu söylemektedir çok zor kadın erkek
eşitsizliği fırsat eşitsizliği işte her
türlü kilo görüntü İmaj bunlardan
yaratılan doğru lan sanal eşitsizlikler
her türlü eşitsizlik dahil olmak üzere
eşitsizlikler bir şekilde prim sağlayan
reyting getiren bir fırsat çıtır satılık
malzemesi olmaya da başladı Ben bunu
gördükçe de böyle inanılmaz bir masanın
altında falan girmek istiyorum her bir
eşitsizlik Savaşı adına ayrı bir slogan
ayrı bir taraf ayrı bir eylem planı
oluşturuldu ve şimdi de bu taraflar
arasındaki savaş çıktı ister istemez
insan savaşa ve kavgaya başvurmadan ve
öfke büyütmeden bir çözüm üret
mı diye düşünüyorum ben saygıyı özledim
eşitsizliğin içinde bir yerlerde saygıyı
anlayışı farklılıkları olan kabul ve
kucaklamayı görmeyi özledim En çok Gözüm
bunu oluyor sanırım eşitsizliklere
Meydan okurken eşitsizliklerden
aldığımız yaraları sarmaya çalışırken
bunlar için hayli ne şefkatli yemekler
verirken Savaş naraları atmadan
birbirimizin acılarından prim yapmadan
ya da küçük görmeden hor görmeden de
eşitsizliklerini adalete verebilecek
oldu bir seçeneği düşünmek istiyorum o
seçenek dedim ki arkadaşlarımın
konuşmalarını dinlerken böyle bir
devrimden bahsediyor ve saygı devrimi
yapmak istiyorum falan diye öyle araya
girmek istedim biz bu kadın erkek
eşitsizliğinden çok çektik yetti diyoruz
gitti derken bir
O başka şiddet bir başka türlü öfke
tehdit takı bize yapıldığı gibi yani
güzeli yapıldıysa aynı şekilde karşılık
verip eşitleniyor Uzo Öfken ağrıları
içerisinde bizi bizim bizde değil olarak
o öfkeyle şiddetini benimsemiş iz
davranışlarımıza Eylem planlarımız da
sirayet etmiş Sanki başka bir seçenek
yokmuşçasına bulduk fırsatını ele
geçirdik Şimdi biz de aynı şekilde tekme
tokat giderek ten bu eşitsizliği eşit
geçirelim diye yıkıp döküyoruz maruz
kaldığımız bütün bu haksızlıklarla
İçinizde biriken o kin öfke ve İntikam
duygularıyla böyle sağa sola tehditler
savurup O hiç hoşlanmadığımız benimsemek
istemediğimiz eşitsizlik içerisinde yeni
bir eşitsizlik yaratıyoruz eşitsizlik
Eğer bir canavar Save biz bu canavardan
çok çekti x.leo çektiğimiz canavardan
kurtulmaya çalışırken yepyeni bir
canavar yaratıyoruz canavarlar
yaratıyoruz Ekim
ne demek istiyorum okul kutumuz
sevmediğimiz canavarın ta kendisi
olmadan da bir yerlere bulabileceğimizi
bunu da saygıyı büyüterek
yapabileceğimize inanıyorum bunu
konuşmak istiyorum eşitsizliklerle
ilgili bir konuşma yapılacak işte sana
eşitsizlikler ne çağrıştırıyor ve sadece
Hatta yazar arkadaşlarına da böyle Beyin
Fırtınası yaptık herkesin ilk aklına
gelen şey ve en çok aklına gelen şeyleri
tek çağrıştırdı şey haksızlık eşitsizlik
deyince aklımıza haksızlık ve
adaletsizlik ten başka hiçbir şey gelmez
olmuş Sonra şöyle bir şey düşündüm
Aslında eşitsizlik matematikte çok net
bir şekilde tanımlanıyor şöyle
tanımlıyor matematik eşitsizliği iki
değer arasındaki farkı ifade eden bir
ilişkidir diyor bir ev bütün o
eşitsizliği negatifliği içerisinde bu
tanımı duymak gerçekten benim kalbimi
ısıttı Çünkü içinde bu tanımın içinde
bu iki değer vardı fark ifade ediliyordu
bir ilişki söz konusuydu ne kadar güzel
bir tanım diye düşündüm Oysa basın
sosyal medya Politikalar politikacılar
reyting verdiğine bütün kargaşa içinde
bize eşitsizliğin kapsadığı ve anlatmak
istediği bu güzel tanımı tamamen yok
etmiş Bunun içindeki zenginlik hiç
görmez hale gelmiş eşitsizlikler
içerisinde Bir değerli bir ilişki
olduğunu farklılıklar olduğunu Bunların
aslında bir zenginlik olduğunu hiç bir
şekilde konuşmuyoruz görmüyoruz depo
tohumu büyütmek için çabalamıyorum gibi
duruyor Oysa bunun için bunu bir duası
var var mesela bir sürü şey geliyor
aklıma işte hani ilişki dediğin şey
iletişimde değil mi iki kişi arasında
iki farklı kişi iki farklı değer
arasında bir iletişim mesela Dertlerimiz
eşit değil o yüzden o yüzden denizden
seninki
ne demek istedim Çünkü ben ne zaman bir
derdim ile ilgili veya dava salınım
arılarla ilgili bir şey yapayım ben dedi
ama canım bu da dersin ki ne dertler var
falan deniliyor bundan çok çektim
Seninki de dert mi sorusuna maruz kalmak
çok acayip bir şey çünkü duygularımız
eşit değil Benim derdim seninkinden
küçük senin derdin benim içinden büyük
Ne yapacağız şimdi yani dertlerimizi bir
karıştıracağız ve bu bizi nereye varacak
yaşlarımız değişiklik dertlerinizin eşit
olmadığı yerde beni Duysana demek
istiyorum yaşlarımız eşit Değil Ben
sizden büyüğüm mesela ve Ne yapacağız
şimdi ben sizden daha büyük olduğum için
sizi ahkam kesme hakkımı oğlu Ya da
sizin benden daha az bir tecrübeniz
olması ile ilgili olarak bu hayatta şu
ana kadar en sizden kazanabilecek
olduğum hiçbir şey yok mu sizin
tecrübelerinizden öğrenecek oldu hiçbir
şey yok mu Ve böyle bir şeyi küçük
görmek hakkını kendini tanımak beni daha
küçük kılmıyor bu
Sen hiç şükretmeyen biriymişim gibi
mesela her seferinde herhangi bir şeyle
karşılaştırıldığında iç çare olarak bir
başkasının derdinin benimkinden daha
büyük olmasını bana yüzüme çarpılması
mesela beni dahaöfkeli daha yalnız
istenen daha çaresiz insan haline
getiriyor konuşmak istemiyorum saklanmak
istiyorum O zaman da derdini
anlatamadığı zamanda Derman bulamıyorsun
aslında yani eşitsizliklerle şöyle bir
şey demek istiyorum duygularımızın eşit
olmadığı bir yerde de ben konuşa
bildiğiniz tartışa bildiğiniz o saygı
alanını yarata bildiğimiz bir yerde
durabilmek istiyorum çeşit olmadığımız
yerde eşitsizliklerle savaşırken saygı
Merhamet anlayış empati büyütmek
istiyorum mesela yıkmak değil yaşatmak
istiyorum iş bu eşitsizlikleri savunan
eşitsizliklere eşit eşitliği getirmeye
çalışırken ve bir dava giderken
bu anlaşılmamış lık ulusal olmamışlık
istenilen değer verilmemiş önem
verilmemiştir hissiyle daha fazla öfke
daha fazla ki daha fazla İntikam daha
fazla inadına söylemleri büyütmeye Özen
göstermek istiyorum hepimizde aramızda
doğal dağlar kadar fark var var
yetiştiğimiz aileler sevdiğimiz yemekler
gittiğimiz okullar iletişim dillerimiz
farklı ve eşit değil Ve iyi ki de öyle
buna İyi ki öyle demeyi unuttuk diye
düşünüyorum Sonra mesela konu Siteler
geliyor böyle sitelerde Yaşamak bir
eşitlenme ortamı olmaya başladı Bunun
altında güvenlik çizdik düzen içinde dik
hoşluk dedi kötü dedik vesaire vesaire
vesaire bir şeyler demeye başladık Ve
Mesela ben bi site içerisinde kendi
evinin penceresini maviye boyayamıyorum
Çünkü Ahengi bozuyor uymuyor hepimizin
aynı düzen
ne yaptık gerekli bazen böyle şey falan
oluyor malzemelerimiz bir örnek mayoyla
mesela denize gidelim Tamam Enişte bu
söyleyince aklıma formalar geliyor E ben
lisede okurken forma giymedi
çocuklarımın forma giymesi gerektiğini
bunu acayip karşı çıktım karşı
çıktığında da böyle inanılmaz bir
karşıtı görüşleri çok yalnız kaldım
Çünkü işte eşitsizlikleri ortadan
kaldıracak imkanı olan çocuklarla imkânı
olmayan çocukların üçte birini çok
kıymetli bir şeyler gerek Okula gelmesi
ile diğer çocuğun bulunan kötü
isteyebilecek olduğu vesaire ve sahibin
tane şeridi politik olarak güldü ve
çocuklara aynı şeyleri giysinler okula
gelsinler Bu eşitsizlik ortadan kalksın
Bence ben çok merak ediyorum o
eşitsizlikler o formaları giyince
duvarlar arkasında bir eşitlik Adaletine
varabildi mi yani formaları girdik de
biz üzerimize eşitlik ve adalet yağdı mı
Bu sadece bir araç olarak kal
bu saklandık o formaların arkasına benim
hayalim de eşit olmayan imkân ve
olanaklar dahilinde de çocukların de
bireylerini insanların yan yana gelip
aynı sırada otura bilmeleri ve bundan
birbirleriyle bağlanabilecek olduklarını
yaşayabilecek oldular olduklarını
görebilmeleri doğru birbirine karşı
saygı duyacaktır Aslında ben ne zaman ki
benimle aynı koşullarda olmayan aynı
geçmişten gelmeyen aynı sürü olmayan
birileriyle arkadaşlarımla giyim lerimiz
farklı olarak yani otura biliyorum O
zaman değişiklikten bahsedebiliriz diye
düşünüyorum geri kalanı Sadece çok ciddi
iki yüzünü kendimizi kandırma ve
yüzleşmeye gerçeği seçimlerimizin farklı
olması nedeniyle eşitsizlik yer
yaşıyoruz şöyle birşey tanıdığım iki
tane genç olağanüstü Şahane ve çok
harika mm üniversiteye kabul edilen yurt
dışında ve bir tane
bu etmeye karar verdi diğeri ben
arkadaşlarından ayrılmak istemediğim
için gitmek istemiyorum dediğini acayip
Mahalle baskısıyla karşılaştığı genç ben
inanamadım yani tercihlerinin Farklı
şekilde kullanmak istediği için böyle
yanlış bir şey yapmış casına bir mahalle
baskısı altında Artık eşitliğini
yitirmişti benim başıma başka bir şey
geldi bununla ilgili Ben söylediğiniz
gibi işte onun ihtiyaçları Derneği teker
Türkiye'nin günleri Vakfı Tolga
gençleriyle beraber koşmaya başladım
bağış topladım ne zaman ki aralar için
bir şey yapmak istiyorum onlar için
konuşmak istiyorum dedim bir anda bulaş
oranı düştü Çünkü aralar için yeterince
acınma duygu sömürüsü Vicdan pornosu
yoktu ve Arılar ve ihtiyaçları diğer
canlıların ihtiyaçlarını asla eşit
görünmedi inanılmaz bir şeydi benim için
hani bunu halbuki bu bir Hakkı Doğuştan
gelen bir hak dediğimizi sahip olduğu
ama orada bir anda eşitsizliğe uğra
daha sonra bu zenginlik kısmı dokunmak
istiyorum çünkü benimle eşit olmayan
eşit koşullarda olmayan birileriyle
yaptığım sohbetlerden bir araya
geldiğinde kazandın tecrübelerin
zenginliğinden ben aldım keyif ne kadar
değerli buldum anlatayım ben mümkün
değil çalıştığım yıllarca çalıştığım çok
uluslu çok büyük kurumsal da 33 farklı
dil dil ırk tanıyor sandık milletinin
sandık tek ortak dilimiz İngilizce
anadili İngilizce olan larında aksanları
farklıydı evimizin İngilizce yetisi
becerisi kabiliyeti ve servise çok
farklı olmasına rağmen hiçbir zaman bir
sorun olmadığı tam tersine inanılmaz bir
müziği bir rengi bir zenginliği vardır
bu ortamı ve biz bu eşitsizliklerini
eşit yiyeceğiz derken mesela
bulunduğumuz genelde şöyle görüyorum
bulunduğumuz çok yüksek mertebeli çok
ben seni çok kültürlü Sırça köşkün
yüzden baktığımız da bir yerleri heryeri
daha aşağıda daha yanda daha az eşit
görmeye başladım ve çok kalp kırıyoruz
ben de yaptım bu mutlu olmuş ve hala
düşündükçe buna çok üzülürüm mesela bunu
da nerede mi fark ettim Ben çok uluslu
dünyada bir şirkette çalışan ronja
olarak o çalışan insan iş insanı olan
oyuncu olarak ona bakış çok farklıydı
duyulan saygı çok farklıydı
konumlandırıldı yer çok farklıydı Ben ne
zaman ki ya ben eve döndük çocuklarımla
kaybettiği zamanı telafi etmek istiyorum
Ben yazmak istiyorum Ben koşmak
istiyorum evde olmak istiyorum dediğinde
bir anda acayip bir düşüşe uğradım Emeğe
saygı itibaren ben böyle bir şey
istemezdim çok iyi eğitimli çok üzüldü
çok okumuş bir insan olarak ben böyle
bir tercih bulunduğu tercihte
bulunduğunda eşitsizlikle cezalandır
alım ve ancak o zaman anladım ki ben
işin sonu Yonca olarak Aslı
o kendi tercihiyle bunun altını çizmek
istiyorum kendi tercihiyle buna karar
vermiş çocuğuyla evi evinde olan bir
kadına asla çok başka bir yerden bakarak
Zaten Zaten Onu mağdur etmiş mi Ben ne
zaman ki onunla aynı noktaya geldim
kendi tercihiyle bir anda orada ayrıldım
Aslında eşitsizlikten her şeyi ben
nerede yaratıyorum bunu nasıl yargılar
ve nasıl inanılmaz yalnızlaştırıyor um
Karşımdaki insan kullanıyorum onun
seçimlerini ev sonra Bunun farkına
varmak asla bana bir şey Düşündürdü
eşitsizlikler bizlere nelere daha fazla
değer vermemiz gerektiğini gösteriyor
Dolayısıyla onun içindeki o zenginliği
kaybetmeden daha yapıcı bir dille
birşeyleri bir yere getirebilmeyi
amaçlıyorum en son olarak temas demek
istiyorum matematik modeller arasındaki
farklı ili
değil yani ilişki İlişki temas demek
sohbet muhabbet iletişim eşitlik Orada
başlıyor Aslında biz birbirimize sohbeti
muhabbeti unuttuk ev giydiğimiz
üzerimize giydiğimiz ol Sözde
üniformalar sorular hepsi çıkartmak
istiyorum farklılıklarımızı
eşitsizliklerini Çıplak gözle görmeyi
onlarla yüzleşmeyi o eşitsizlikleri
görerek duyarak bilerek dokunarak saygı
duyarak Merhamet büyüterek empati
duyarak yan yana yaşayabilmek istiyorum
Ben bütün bu eşitsizliklere temas
ederken karşındakini dilimlerine elimle
dövmek ve söylemek istemiyorum sarılarak
kucaklayarak alan açarak yer vererek
kabul ederek eşitliğe davet etmek
istiyorum o şekilde Adaleti sağlamayı ve
bulmayı hayal ediyorum mesela dağın
yüksekte olması sayesinde yağmur suları
Oradan aşağıya a
bu Akarsu beni yerlerde okyanusları
oluşur ve bu iki böyle yani daha ve
deniz aynı seviyede olsa biz bu doğal
süreci yaşayacağız köydeki Her çocuğun
ihtiyacın Bizim baktığımız yerden
ayağındaki çift çıplak ayağını bir
ayakkabı olmaya bildiğini Veya bizim
çocuklarımızın daha Köye gittiğinde
ayaklarını toprağa çıplak basabilecek
olduğu konusundaki farklı
eşitsizliklerin güzelliğini görmeye
devam edebilmek istiyorum ev Seninki de
dert mi yargısız infaz yerine herkesin
derdinin Onun için yeterince büyük
olduğunu varsayarak ve anlayarak
dinleyebilme yi yargılayamaz
yargılamadan işte olabilmeyi istiyorum
aralara değil Neden bitireceğim tabi
çıktı konuşmayı aralar dik olan içinde
binlerce ör düşünün her sabah işe
koyuyorlar bütün işçi Arılar dişi
Ben her sabah güneş de bir kovandan
çıkıp uçmaya başladıklarında hem
kendilerinin hem bütünün hayrına diyerek
Binlerce çiçek like masa geçiyorlar ve o
Arılar o işçi dişi Arılar hiç bir gün
ben şu çiçeği konulan konarsan sadece
Sarıçiçek ona kolları Morgan polen
alırım bu yaptığında da bu büyükler Bana
karşı çok büyük saygısızlık yaptılar
yıllardır onların yüzünden Koreliler
söylüyorum o yüzden sadece bu çocuk
çocuk balı çocuklara vereceğim geri
kalan büyükler hepsinde sokmaya karar
verdim gibi İntikam hareket etmiyorlar
Dolayısıyla insan Hem kendinin hem
bütünün hayrına çalışmayı amaçladığını
İşin özü savaştan çok Barış al
haksızlıktan çok adalete de bağırıyor ve
eşitsizliklerden konuşmada tek adet
kalmıyor ve birbirimize baktığımızda
farklarımız içindeki zenginliğe saygıyla
temas edersek çok başka bir yere
varacağımız düşünüyorum bahçemizin
zenginliği onu ettiğiniz farklı farklı
değil birbiriyle ilişkisi ve birbirini
beslenmesiyle mümkün Ben Bahçemde
eşitlik adına saygı sevgi adalet
anlayışı Barış büyütmek istiyorum
eşitsizliklerini izle öfkeyle kaldı
kalkıp zarar büyütmek yerine aşk ve
muhabbetiniz artsın istiyorum Çok
teşekkür ederim çocuklar